britain's second largest airport a
handful of flights a smattering of
passengers
but could that change soon it's
certainly looking at all the options
here and
we don't want to get left behind by
countries which may be adopting uh
two jabs approach uh if it can be done
safely and if it can be done
carefully and securely ministers are
considering whether they could get back
to this
to allow more of this but only if you've
had
both jabs we're about to be double
jabbed and i made sure those
appointments were booked for our second
job
today for tens of millions of people it
could make a world of difference
my husband's portuguese and we're just
having such
bad luck with the quality we just can't
quarantine we come back my husband's job
is customer facing
and you know he just can't you know a
holiday ends up doubling in price when
you
calculate loss of earnings etc and then
when it went on the green list this time
we were like
so excited that we've got a newborn baby
we're gonna go and see family who we
haven't seen for now two years
and then for it to just go back to amber
we're just you know we're just
heartbroken
keeping the borders all but closed
places like this gatwick airport
basically empty is politically
popular that's why some people think
that matt hancock
took portugal off the green list a
couple of weeks back because of that
nepal variant which we've heard
conspicuously little about since
but there are some government who are
fighting back they want to save the
travel industry and the british summer
overseas
now i'm told it's going to be very hard
to get
european countries on the green list so
they're looking to change the definition
of what
it means to be an amber country but it's
not going to be easy
that hasn't stopped the excitement
growing it's actually the difference
between being able to go and not being
able to just because
i am a healthcare worker here i do have
a lot of patients and a lot of
obligations
and i just cannot let myself allow
10 days of quarantine because it's just
a waste of time and money
i think it's a good idea because
personally i've had two jobs
and i don't feel that it is fair to be
lumped into the same category
as people that haven't had any jabs
obviously you know
i feel that i should be able to fly the
plan would create a
generational divide putting the young at
a disadvantage
which some find unconscionable you're
identifying a group
of people that have actually made huge
sacrifices for those
who are older and in the higher risk
categorization
so for those people to see the group
that they've made sacrifices for being
allowed to do something they they cannot
is unfair
and i think that's why it's absolutely
essential that we really crack through
the population now get those jabs
hopes have been raised today about
foreign holidays but with 11 000 or more
cases may be raised
too high there are many many obstacles
sam coats guy news